[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle séance de questions
de contrôle au sénat pendant l'épidémie
de coronavirus les sénateurs continuent
d'interroger une fois par semaine le
gouvernement sur sa gestion de la crise
et sur les conséquences économiques et
sociales de cette situation
la séance commence dans quelques minutes
à 15 heures dans des conditions qui
respectent les consignes sanitaires je
le précise onze questions sont au
programme cet après midi à venir de
l'hôpital public souveraineté numérique
gestion des masques
jérôme durain est avec moi un sénateur
socialiste de saône-et-loire la gestion
des masques c'est d'ailleurs et bien le
sujet de votre propre question quelle
question voulez vous adresser au
gouvernement laissez passer un épisode
un peu malheureux en fin de semaine
dernière puisque une commande de masques
passer par la région grand est et
bourgogne franche comté était
réquisitionnée par l'état sans autre
forme de procès directement sur le
tarmac sans coup de fil préalable aux
élus locaux et on ne peut pas alors
qu'on est tous en train d'essayer de
contribuer à la résolution de la crise
voir l'état passé comme ça un peu de
manière flibustière devant les
collectivités pour prendre leurs propres
commandes ses réquisitions précisant le
elles sont légales 1 il ya eu un décret
dès le début du mois de mars et puis il
ya eu ensuite la loi du 22 mars dernier
mais quel impact justement pour votre
région votre région que voulait-il faire
de ces masques et notre région voulaient
utiliser ces masques en coordination
avec les services de l'état dans la
région le préfet la rs les distribuer à
des ehpad à des personnels soignants
contribuer à notre manière à
l'amélioration de la situation de ceux
qui sont en première ligne
sauf que l'état en prenant les masques
sans le dire à personne vient perturber
ses plans
c'est un peu méprisant pour nos propres
populations gants grand test ils ont
besoin le masque mais nous aussi
c'est un peu curieux parce qu'on parle
avec les représentants de l'état au plan
local et au niveau central on a un peu
l'impression tout ça est gérée de
manière un peu aléatoire une
désorganisation des organisations
étaient pas que c'est une armée
mexicaine mais c'est la guerre nous
dit-on on est censé travailler ensemble
donc il faut un plan de bataille il faut
un état major et fines organisées sur
des troupes des consignes claires
de l'anticipation ça fait défaut pour le
moment que pensez vous justement du
virage qui a été amorcée par le
gouvernement sur les masques ces masques
est in qui était jugée pas nécessaire au
début de la crise au début de l'épidémie
et aujourd'hui on voit que c'est en
train de changer notamment par hiaumet
avec les préconisations des médecins
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ces crises personne n'aimerait à avoir
en gérer les conséquences personne mais
on voit bien quand même qu'à des
évolutions dans les doctrines et dans
les consignes qui sont passés qui sont
préjudiciables à la protection des
populations et à la bonne application
des directives de l'état sur le terrain
donc il faut stabiliser les consignes
que les mots d'ordre soit univoque que
l'état ne parle que d'une voix et qu'on
puisse tous se ranger derrière la
bannière de l'état parce qu'on veut tous
contribué citoyens élus à la résolution
de cette crise sanitaire à protéger les
populations est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut les rendre obligatoires partout
comme par exemple souhaite un certain
nombre de maires qui ont pris des
arrêtés et qui font en sorte que ce soit
le cas dans leur commune moi je n'ai pas
de parti pris sur le sujet je ne suis
pas scientifique un comité scientifique
nous on fera comme élu ce que l'état
dira qu'il convient de faire
on a un gouvernement fait confiance au
gouvernement il faut stabiliser les
consignes et tout le monde se mettre en
donnant derrière la la directive qui
sera passée pour conclure une dernière
question à jérôme durain après la mort
du maire de san luis de saint-louis
aujourd'hui dans le haut-rhin et bien
cela soulève une grande vague d'émotion
une nouvelle fois beaucoup d'élus
notamment du grand est sont atteints par
le coronavirus certains dénoncent et
bien l'impact de la campagne des
élections municipales et la tenue de ces
élections
est ce que c'est votre cas oui moi je
pense que dans la période où l'on se
trouve
il faut d'avoir une pensée pour tous
ceux qui sont malades ceux qui sont
partis on éclaircira les raisons des
départs la patience s'est propagée est
ce que c'est parce qu'un cluster dans
cette région est ce que c'est parce
qu'elles étaient des interactions à la
faveur des élections c'est pas le moment
pour l'instant lutte contre la crise
tout ça sera étudiée plus tard pour
l'instant lutte contre la crise merci
beaucoup
jérôme durain d'avoir répondu à mes
questions à votre place et bien va venir
désormais vincent capo-canellas qui est
sénateur uc de la seine saint denis
vincent capo-canellas vous allez poser
tout à l'heure une question sur les
violences conjugales
et familiale qui augmente avec le
confinement c'est un phénomène qui n'est
pas que français
c'est un phénomène mondial d'ailleurs
l'onu a exhorté les états à agir sur le
sujet est ce que pour vous aujourd'hui
via les dispositifs qui sont mis en
place sont suffisants je crois que très
tôt la délégation aux droits des femmes
du sénat a alerté et qui a une
mobilisation pour demander au
gouvernement des mesures ces mesures ont
été prises dans un premier temps
maintenant on a des interrogations sur
l'ampleur de l'effort budgétaire qui va
être réalisé et puis sur le suivi parce
qu'on sait tous que les violences
intrafamiliales les violences faites aux
femmes que les violences faites en
direction des enfants dans un milieu de
confinement évidemment elles sont moins
visibles et à moins de capacités alerté
- capacité à assurer le suivi
il ya aussi un enjeu avec les
départements qui assure une partie
importante de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et donc je voulais savoir comment le
gouvernement va coordonner tout ça et
ensuite comment se projette pas aussi
dans la sortie du confinement parce qu'à
ce moment là on verra
l'ampleur des difficultés qui ont été
rencontrés l'ampleur des problèmes
donc mon propos est d'alerter le
gouvernement avec le ministre les
principales chaînes plus de
clarifications sur le budget notamment
combien de gars et millions qui a été
annoncé on se savoure un peu d'où il
vient et comment il va être bien en
oeuvre évidemment mais notre
préoccupation c'est la coordination de
l'ensemble des acteurs pour être au plus
près du terrain et que ces violences là
où puisque lutter contre elle je le
précisais vous êtes sénateur de seine
saint denis
votre département est particulièrement
touchée par les coronavirus pour quelles
raisons selon vous la scène zannier
touché comme tous les départements qui
malheureusement connaissent une
progression importante du du virus ne
sommes pas le seul département mais nous
avons des difficultés particulières avec
notamment une offre de soins qui
structurellement est inférieur offre
hospitalière
mais je veux saluer la mutualisation à
l'échelle de toute l'ile-de-france et
l'échelle du pays
et dire que l'ensemble de la chaîne
sanitaire l'ensemble des professions de
santé sont vraiment mobilisés
la difficulté est difficultés existant
sainte anne il faudra en plus
stigmatisés ce département je crois
qu'il a c'est la solidarité
il est certain qu'ils ont dit
le confinement n'a pas été respectée
depuis on comprend bien que ce n'est pas
vraiment le problème en seine saint
denis c'est plutôt des problèmes
structurels et vous l'avez dit cette
fracture qui ont qu'on a souvent dénoncé
qui est souvent dénoncent les élus de
seine-saint-denis
elle ne fait que s'amplifier avec la
crise il ya eu différents rapports
rapport parlementaire d'ailleurs pour
souligner la faiblesse des moyens en
direction de ce département le prévenu
sera annoncé des mesures elles ne sont
que plus que jamais nécessaire voilà il
ya une solidarité aussi au quotidien qui
fait que ont fait face à ces difficultés
qui sont évidemment dramatique partout
en france et des mesures ont été prises
dans plusieurs départements franciliens
et à paris pour interdire les activités
sportives en journée est ce que ça va
être le cas aussi en seine-saint-denis
pour le moment je n'ai pas d'information
particulière l'atuge le préfet fait une
audioconférence tout à l'heure on aura
l'occasion d'en bas d'en parler
évidemment faut que chacun comprenne des
restrictions restrictions aux libertés
bien sûr mais on peut pas non plus
demander à certains de ne pas sortir et
à d'autres accepter qu'ils puissent
sortir faire un footing ya dans certains
départements des dispositions sur les
heures pourquoi pas une dernière
question vincent capo-canellas et bien
sûr le côté économique de cette crise
une crise énorme a dit bruno le maire
qui est peut être comparée à celle de 29
il a commencé à entrouvrir la porte
devant la commission des affaires
économiques en parlant de possible
annulation de charges dans les secteurs
les plus en crise
est ce que vous le souhaitez je crois
que c'est une nécessité
il ya eu beaucoup de différer de charge
mais on sait tous que lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de chiffre d'affaires lorsqu'il a
pas de rentrées d'argent à un moment
donné il faudra quand même payer ses
charges
les différer ça veut dire aussi qu'on va
faire grandir la note est que à un
moment donné il faudra à minima des
étalements pendant très longtemps et qu'
il faudrait comme l'allemagne l'a fait
aboutir à des différés pour répondre au
maintien de l'activité économique des
petites entreprises notamment
eh bien merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
mes questions c'est françois patriat qui
va maintenant venir le président du
groupe la république en marche au sénat
françois patriat bonjour tout à l'heure
avec jérôme durain nous parlions des
réquisitions de stocks par l'exécutif
stocks de masques commandés par votre
région
donc en bourgogne franche comté est-ce
que vous aussi vous trouvez que c'est
une situation qu'il faut dénoncer qui
n'est pas acceptable dénonce pas parce
que leurs
aujourd'hui est à la lutte contre la
maladie au soutien en soignant il vous
soutien aux malades
l'heure n'est pas à la polémique il ya
un décret ok fixés par la loi et un
décret qui fixe le niveau au delà duquel
est à peut réquisitionner pour répartir
mieux sur le territoire en fonction des
besoins
donc j'imagine bien que il ya eu en la
matière frustration la part de la région
bourgogne je suis moi même intervenu
auprès des membres du gouvernement pour
venir avant sera très jeune cela avait
présidé en fin de compte je pense que
faut dépasser cette polémique et penser
que la région bourgogne franche comté
comme d'autres auront leur répartition
des musiques dès qu'ils attendent qu'ils
ont parfois financés qu'il mérite et il
faut donc mieux coordonner peut-être
l'action des régions des collectivités
et de l'état c'est aussi ça le problème
tout ce qui peut mieux faire fonctionner
que je suis favorable bien entendu je
pense que cette coordination elle
intervient et que c'est au niveau de
l'état on sait particulièrement partout
sur le territoire français il ya des
urgences
que ce soit dans le milieu hospitalier
le personnel soignant ou dans les ehpad
est ce que pour vous il ya eu un
changement de doctrine par l'exécutif
sur la gestion des masques et sur le
fait que les masques qui était au début
j'ai pas nécessaire aujourd'hui de plus
en plus on dit qu'ils sont nécessaires
et même certains maires vont jusqu'à les
rendre obligatoires dans leur commune
je comprends bien qu'il ya un effet
psychologique est important un effet
médical moi je ne suis pas apte pour le
à le juger
c'est quoi je crois c'est ce que le
gouvernement dit qu'il n'ya pas tout le
monde doctrine autant pour protéger les
masques et masques ils sont faits pour
protéger surtout les autres pas se
protéger soi même
or dans l'esprit des gens et masques
pour se protéger eux mêmes je crois que
la doctrine ou énormément qu'il dit
quand méthode de confinement sans doute
comme top de déconfinement il faudra
sans doute à la fois faire des tests et
avoir des masques pour éviter que des
gens puisse contaminer d'autres à ce
moment-là nous paraît bonne docte et
bien merci beaucoup
françois patriat d'avoir répondu à mes
questions puisque gérard larcher est en
train d'arriver un pour le début de
cette séance de questions de contrôle au
gouvernement je vous le précise ans il
ya donc onze questions qui sont prévues
cet après-midi tout centré autour du
coronavirus c'est une séance de contrôle
qui va permettre aux sénateurs
d'interroger le gouvernement sur sa
gestion de la crise
mais aussi sur les conséquences
économiques et les conséquences sociales
de cette crise sans précédent voilà la
cloche vient de sonner tout de suite on
prend la direction de l'hémicycle sur
notre site internet
ce n'est pas reçue d'observation il y en
a t'il en séance je n'en vois point il
est donc adopté mes chers collègues les
conclusions adoptées par la conférence
des présidents réunie hier sont
consultables sur le site du sénat
elle prévoit le maintien chaque mercredi
d'une séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement sur le format adapté
restreint déjà mis en place pour le
restant des semaines du mois d'avril
en l'absence d'observation je les
considère donc comme adoptées elles sont
adoptées
monsieur le premier ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues leur religion rappelle des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat mais je souhaite
excuser notre le ministre marc fesneau
retenu par un deuil familial et auquel
je souhaite exprimer au nom du sénat
toute notre sympathie dans l'épreuve que
sa famille et lui même traverse gelé
hier au téléphone et qui sache que ce
soit la conférence des présidents que
les présidents de groupes réunis
vraiment s'associe très directement à ce
que je viens de dire au nom du sénat
tout entier
la parole est maintenant au président
françois patriat pour le groupe de la
république en marche vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
j'emprunte des propos que vous avez
tenus là quelques instants monsieur le
président pour dire que leur l'or
aujourd'hui et à la lutte contre
l'épidémie
l'heure est au soutien au personnel
soignant rien d'autre l'heure est au
soutien aux malades qui souffrent avec
leurs familles de cette monstrueuse
maladie la france ce premier ministre
entre ces jours ci dans la quatrième
semaine de confinement confinement qui
sera sans doute appelé à être prolongée
ce dont chacun parmi nous et ailleurs
est bien conscient leurs futurs
collègues est plus que jamais à l'unité
nationale comme l'a toujours su faire
notre peuple dans les moments très
difficiles dans six périodes tragiques
unité nationale et je l'espère aussi
je sais que c'est difficile unités
européennes j'entends bien ici et là se
lever les critiques certains donneurs de
leçons divers longs pape qui cherche à
informer ou à participer mais qui
cherchent plutôt instauré par avance des
procès pour cet instant malvenue la
critique est aisée mais l'art est
difficile
mais un sondage de ce matin montrent que
67% des français disent avoir bon moral
malgré la situation sanitaire et les
mesures de confinement
nous savons que le pic de la maladie est
encore devant nous même si la courbe
s'est aplani et heureusement
cependant nul ne peut nier que les
conséquences économiques sociales seront
gravés impactante en remerciant à mon
tour toutes celles et ceux qui
participent à l'effort national au
personnel soignant bien entendu sans
oublier les français qui suivent les
consignes de sécurité
pourriez vous monsieur le ministre nous
faire part du bilan de ses trois
premières semaines de confinement sur le
plan de la santé mais aussi bien sûr sur
le plan économique et social
au vu de toutes les mesures importantes
qui ont été prises avec l'accord de
notre assemblée le plus souvent par le
gouvernement et ceci de façon à faire
bien comprendre et entendons français
que leurs efforts paient et à les
encourager à les poursuivre je vous
remercie pour vos répondre la parole est
à monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président patriat vous m'interrogez sur
un point d'étape ou en réalité sur le
sur le confinement
d'abord un mot pour dire que
la mesure de confinement qui a été
décidé a été décidée en fonction d'une
stratégie qui consistait à faire en
sorte que le nombre de cas sévères de
malades lesquels justifie une
hospitalisation et parfois une admission
en service de réanimation ne dépasse pas
la capacité d'accueil des services de
réanimation français c'était l'objectif
du confinement pour faire face au nombre
de camarades nous avons le nombre de cas
sévères nous avons considérablement
augmenter notre capacité d'accueil dans
les services de réanimation
je le dis parce que c'est un c'est en
vérité un succès à bas bruit la capacité
qu'a eue le système hospitalier le
système de soins français à passer d'une
capacité normale de 5000 lits de
réanimation à plus de 10000 livres
journaux et à pouvoir continuer à
accueillir dans des conditions de
tension considérable
un nombre de malades en situation très
grave
pendant souvent une très longue période
est exceptionnel
la mobilisation du système de soins
évidemment l'engagement des personnels
soignants
il faut le souligner le répéter le
mettre en évidence mais au delà des
personnels soignants tout ce qui
concourt à l'offre de soin les
personnels administratifs dans les ars
ont fait un travail remarquable pour
permettre justement cette montée en
puissance des capacités de réanimation
et ceux qui ont organisé les évacuations
sanitaires auxquels nous avons procédé
soit entre régions soit vers l'étranger
ont aussi réalisé un exploit logistique
jamais jamais réalisée en france
dans cette nature mais jamais même
imaginer dans ces proportions et c'est
un des grands succès du système
hospitalier qu'il faut saluer à sa juste
mesure
nous sommes au moment où nous parlons à
un moment de l'épidémie où le nombre
d'augmentations le nombre d'admissions
en service de réanimation qui donc l'
indicateur essentiel que nous suivons à
ce stade est en ralentissement
il progresse encore
mais avec un une progression qui est
désormais très lente très lente
nous avons dépassé les 7000 cas en
réanimation malades du cobp id plus de
7000 cas si du jamais vu j'avais eu sept
mille personnes en service de
réanimation à cause de la même maladie
en france et nous avons jusqu'à présent
réussi à pouvoir accueillir dans les
services de réanimation suffisamment de
malades tous les malades ont cassé vers
l'élément qui laisse entrevoir peut-être
et vous remarquerez que je suis prudent
monsieur le président patriat peut-être
un peu d'espoir c'est que cette
progression se ralentit au point que
peut-être nous arrivons à quelque chose
qui ressemblerait un plateau encore je
dis les choses prudemment quelque chose
qui ressemblerait un plateau c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
si ça se confirme et c'est très
probablement très certainement là
l'effet du confinement de ce point de
vue cette évolution ce ralentissement de
la courbe des admissions réanimation
vient confirmer la nécessité du
confinement
c'est ce que l'on peut faire ce dont on
peut faire état s'agissant du bilan
sanitaire ce qui m'incite évidemment et
ce qu'ils m'invitent évidemment à dire
que on peut faire un point d'étape mais
on ne peut pas faire le bilan définitif
du confinement car le confinement est
appelée à durer si il ne durait pas ou
s'ils n'étaient pas respectées nous
prendrions le risque qui en vérité ne
serait pas un risque qui serait une
certitude de voir le virus circule est à
nouveau très vite et donc le nombre de
cas a admis en réanimation augmenté
alors même que le tissu hospitalier a
été sur sollicité et qui se trouve dans
un état de stress
de fatigue qu'il faut évidemment bien
avoir en tête c'est la raison pour
laquelle je dis régulièrement que leur
dû des confinement n'est pas venue toute
notre énergie doit être consacré à faire
en sorte que le confinement soit
respecté pour que les effets positifs de
ce confinement puisse se confirmer dans
le nombre de cas sévères admis en
réanimation
j'espère que je suis claire en disant
les choses ainsi c'est le premier
élément de bilan que je peux donner à
votre appréciation en ajoutant qu' un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes qui étaient
les nôtres notamment sur la capacité à
fournir des médicaments
compte tenu de l'augmentation incroyable
de l'utilisation de ces médicaments en
france et partout dans le monde
au même moment et un rythme
incroyablement intense que nous savons
faire face nous savons faire face à ce
risque est que je m'en félicite
le confinement il a donc un effet
sanitaire positif s'agissant du coc vite
il a un effet sanitaire qu'il ne faut
pas négliger et qui peut être négatif
c'est évidemment le moindre recours aux
soins de tous ceux qui malades ou étant
susceptible de tomber malade au moins
recours à l'offre de soin parce qu'il
leur est difficile d'aller chez le
médecin parce qu'il leur est difficile
de trouver le spécialiste qui parfois à
fermer son activité ça peut arriver des
exemples assez précis en tête dans une
ville qui m'est cher et donc nous savons
que le confinement un impact sanitaire
qui peut être négatif vers d'autres que
ceux qui seraient susceptibles de
pouvoir être admis en réanimation à
l'hôpital et je l'a dit parce que le
ministre hier à l'occasion de sa prise
de parole a été très clair sur l'enjeu
sanitaire qui s'attache à à pouvoir ne
pas lier à faire en sorte que les soins
continuent à être prodigué les soins de
ville continue à être prodigués des
examens continue de prodiguer alors même
qu'on est dans une période de
confinement c'est évidemment un objectif
sanitaire essentiel c'est le deuxième
point que je veux souligner s'agissant
du bilan du coup fumant un troisième
point évidemment c'est l'impact
économique il est massif il est très
négatif il est brutale et il va susciter
en france comme partout dans le monde
les impacts nationaux se répondant et
amplifiant encore la donne
il va se traduire par un choc économique
que chacun imagine mais dont personne ne
sait encore la totalité de l'impact
le bilan que je peux faire des mesures
qui ont été prises
j'en arrêterait à ce stade c'est que le
dispositif que vous avez adopté de
chômage partiel et que nous avons
proposé est très fortement sollicités ce
sont aujourd'hui près de 6 millions de
salariés qui sont couverts par le
chômage partiel
c'est absolument considérable et bien
entendu cela a un coût collectif
absolument considérer les reports de
charges fiscales et sociales ont permis
de soulager de près de 7 milliards
d'euros la trésorerie des entreprises
pour le seul mois de mars c'est là aussi
évidemment quelque chose d'important
le fonds de solidarité qui étaient
installés et qui est financé par l'état
par les assureurs et par les régions les
taillant verser 750 millions les assurés
rayon verte et s'en prend des premiers
millions qu'ils ont versé pour 1200
millions et les régions versant bientôt
je le crois leur contribution ce fonds
de solidarité a répondu a reçu près de
700000 demande alors qu'il a été créé au
début de la semaine 700 milles demandé à
distribuer ou est sur le point de
distribuer 700 millions d'euros aux tpe
les plus durement frappés par la crise
enfin le prêt garanti par l'état se
déploie rapidement avec des pré accord
de financement qui porte sur plus de 13
milliards au jour où à l'heure où je
vous parle plus de 13 milliards donc la
réponse est passive mais ne nous voilons
pas la face l'impact sera considérable
il est encore beaucoup trop tôt pour
l'apprécier puisqu'il sera très
directement liée à la durée de
confinement est que cette durée de
confinement est appelée aujourd'hui
de toute évidence a duré quelques temps
encore on aura l'occasion de revenir sur
ce point je crois
voilà ce que je pouvais dire au sénat
sur la question vous me posez monsieur
le président merci monsieur le premier
ministre
avant l'été au président jean claude
requier pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social et européen
la parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur lévis mais sa
collègue
après maintenant plus de trois semaines
de confinement l'immense majorité de nos
concitoyens a pris la mesure des règles
de sécurité sanitaire a pas appliquée
bien sûr tous ces contraintes sont
difficiles à vivre
je me réjouis de la vertu civique de
tous ceux qui ont compris que nous
vaincrons aussi ce virus par notre
responsabilité collective mais à charge
également pour l'état de transmettre des
recommandations claires et cohérentes
qui sont d'autant plus efficaces
je voudrais aussi évoqué la situation
des commerces alimentaires qui assure
chaque jour l'approvisionnement de notre
pays sa rupture majeure
je salue en particulier les responsables
le personnel et notamment tous les
salariés de ce secteur dont nous
mesurons encore plus l'importance alors
qu'ils travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles parfois angoissantes
nous devons les protéger pour beaucoup
aller faire ses courses est devenue la
seule sortie cra même parfois un effet
promenade et responsables lorsque cette
sortie devient familiale où s'étire dans
la durée or si votre gouvernement a déjà
restreint les marchés qui se tiennent à
nos yeux ouverts aucune norme encore été
édictées pour préciser les conditions
d'accueil du public dans les grandes
surfaces et protéger les salariés comme
les pires cette augmentation est
pourtant indispensable dès lors que les
grandes surfaces capte l'essence et la
distribution alimentaire et peuvent en
outre ram d'autres produits monsieur le
premier ministre les propositions sont
déjà sur la table par exemple la loire
atlantique où notre groupe de soutien
scientifique initiée par entre collègues
ronan dantec a fait plusieurs
recommandations validées régionalement
paraissent comme la nécessité de se
laver les mains à l'entrée en espagne
également où il est même de la rédiger
un panier minimum de course pour
justifier une sortie c'est le premier
ministre allez vous saisir le haut
conseil de la santé publique de ce sujet
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mesures prises dans le pied
plusieurs éléments pour répondre à votre
question est d'abord allé dans le sens
de ce que vous indiquez c'est à dire le
coup de chapeau à l'ensemble de la
chaîne qui va des producteurs
alimentaires aux distributeurs
quel que soit d'ailleurs la forme que
cette distribution prend pour dire que
nous avons un système en france qui l'a
aussi tiens et permet de ne pas
connaître de pénuries alimentaires et de
ne pas avoir à subir ou un train dhr de
pénurie alimentaire ce qui là aussi est
un remarquable exemple de résilience
même si tout ça ça s'effectue dans des
conditions qui sont parfois difficiles
je le sais nous avons réussi le pays va
dire nous le pays a réussi à trouver une
façon de garantir l'approvisionnement
alimentaire et je veux saluer tous ceux
qui participent à cette a7 et fort
qu'ils soient producteurs agriculteurs
mais aussi à l'ensemble de la commerce
et de la distribution grande
distribution qui a été mis très en avant
à juste titre et aussi beaucoup de
petits commerces artisans de boulanger
notamment qui continue à exercer leur
activité dont nous avons besoin et qui
grâce à cela réussisse à à la fois
conserver parfois un minimum de lien
social ce qui est utile et aussi surtout
à garantir le bon approvisionnement
alimentaire
je voulais saluer comme vous l'avez fait
monsieur le président je veux rappeler
du reste que l'ensemble des commerces
alimentaires peut fonctionner et que
doit pouvoir fonctionner autant qu'il
est capable de garantir évidemment la
sécurité sanitaire et le bon
fonctionnement de son de son activité
vous n'avez évoqué des règles les règles
ce sont d'abord les règles générales le
respect des gestes barrières le respect
de cette distanciation physique ou
distanciation social que chacun doit
respecter
j'oserais volontiers par une formule
monsieur le président hockey dire que
face à une épidémie
le courage c'est le civisme et donc le
respect d'une règle commune c'est ça le
courage c'est civisme et que nous avons
besoin de civisme que nous avons besoin
de civisme y compris dans l'acte le plus
quotidien d'acheter son teint et donc de
garder cette distanciation physique de
respecter toute une série de règles mais
cet appel au civisme cet appel
j'allais dire au bon sens qui prévaut
dans l'immense majorité des cas vous le
savez nous savons tous qui prévaut dans
l'immense majorité des cas ne suffit pas
et il faut évidemment pouvoir organiser
les choses de telle façon que la
sécurité sanitaire puisse être en toute
mesure assuré c'est la raison pour
laquelle la ministre du travail avec les
organisations syndicales avec toute une
série d'experts a lancé une réflexion
visant à produire des guides de bonnes
pratiques qui métier par métier activité
par activité vienne indiqué ce qui
convient de faire pour respecter les
règles de façon très concrète souvent
très imagé en ayant pour objectif
principal de fixer ou de proposer des
bonnes conduites qui garantisse à tous
qu'on atteint l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés je crois qu'il en existe
trois désormais qui sont applicables
dans les métiers de la distribution pour
la boulangerie pour les métiers de
caisse et pour un autre dont le
trois guides de bonnes pratiques qui
s'applique dans les métiers que vous
avez indiqué ça j'en suis certain
j'invite l'ensemble de ceux qui
participent à cette chaîne d'activités à
se reporter à ces guides de bonnes
pratiques et à les mettre en oeuvre
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons faire
prévaloir à la fois les règles de bonne
conduite
les règles de civisme les règles de
sécurité sanitaire et la poursuite
nécessaire de l'activité dire qu'il faut
que les petits artisans du commerce
alimentaire aussi bien que les surfaces
les grandes surfaces de distribution
alimentaires puissent continuer leurs
activités et survivre en ce moment est
indispensable car elle apporte un
service à la nation qui est inestimable
je le dis qui est inestimable dans une
période de confinement il ne peut pas y
avoir que l'activité hospitalière où
l'activité de soins il faut bien que
notre pays continue à manger il faut
bien que notre pays continue à pouvoir
disposer d'électricité il faut bien que
toute une série d'activités puisse être
assurée parfois avec un service minimum
c'est vrai mais de façon à ce que les
chaînes logistiques ne s'interrompent
pas et ne viennent pas perturber une
fine et la continuité de la vie de la
nation
autrement dit respect du civisme coup de
chapeau à ceux qui organisent cette
production et cette distribution guide
de bonnes pratiques et comme ça monsieur
le président j'espère que tout se
passera pour le club merci monsieur le
produit le président roquet a parlé à
notre collègue pierre laurent pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologique j'avais la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre quand la pandémie a frappé
notre pays
médecins et personnels soignants vous
alertaient depuis des années vous
refusiez de les écouter quand après
notre tour de france des hôpitaux
nous avons déposé un projet de loi
d'urgence fin 2019 vous avez refusé de
nous écouter fin 2019 toujours vous avez
fait voter en plfss tellement
insuffisant qui hier le bureau de la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
soutenue unanimement la demande d'un
plfss rectificatif aujourd'hui médecins
et personnels se donne corps et à bhl
admirable pour sauver des vies tout le
pays les soutiens mais ils ont la rage
au coeur le dévouement n'a pas effacé la
colère soyez en sûr aujourd'hui vos mots
changent vous dit rien ne sera plus
comme avant
le président de la république a au fil
de ses déclarations déclaré je cite que
la santé gratuite est un bien précieux
qu'il ait des biens et des services qui
doivent être placés en dehors des lois
du marché qu'un plan d'investissement
massif devra être conduits pour
l'hôpital public
que vont devenir ces mots monsieur le
ministre nous apprenons par exemple avec
stupéfaction par mediapart qu'une note
d'experts de la caisse d'aidé pour
commandés par l'elysée prévoit au
contraire d'aggraver la marchandisation
de la santé et de l'hôpital c'est
hallucinant alors que dans le pays les
balcons non seulement applaudissent mais
maintenant se couvre de banderole pour
demander comme le dit par exemple une
pétition qui vient de se couvrir de cent
mille signatures en quelques jours de
l'argent pour l'hopital pas pour le
capital monsieur le ministre j'ai deux
questions
pouvez-vous démentir que l'orientation
prônée par la note de la cdc soit
actuellement envisagée et deuxièmement
comment va être travaillés le futur plan
pub pour l'hôpital et pour la stratégie
de santé publique par qui va être
travaillées ce plan par quel processus
transparent en clair qu'elle élaboration
démocratique
allez-vous mettre en place dans le pays
au parlement pour que rien ne soit plus
vraiment comme avant
à commencer par votre méthode de
gouvernement on vous répondent la parole
est au ministre de la solidarité de la
santé monsieur olivier veyrat savez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur pierre laurent
merci pour votre question qui porte sur
l'hôpital le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion de répondre
il ya quelques minutes sur ce que
l'hôpital est capable de produire
d'incroyables dans notre pays
moi j'ai toujours considéré et je sais
que vous aussi que l'hôpital public
l'hôpital privé aussi est un outil
puissamment moderne agile capable de
soulever des montagnes
capable de doubler voire tripler ses
lits de réanimation quand il le faut
pour sauver des vies capable de
mobiliser son personnel d'un bout à
l'autre de la france du jour au
lendemain pour être capable d'aller
sauver des vies et que cet hôpital
puissamment moderne très fort il nous
permet alors que semble comme l'a dit le
premier ministre se profiler le plateau
de cette vague épidémique nous permet
d'avoir évité des situations humaines
puis désastreuse encore telle que celle
que nous avons pu constater à l'étranger
c'est pourquoi nous avons annoncé déjà
la semaine dernière que toutes les
opérations de restructurations
hospitalières tous les plans même les
plans qui sont soutenus par des élus
quel que soit le bord politique y
compris d'ailleurs parfois du vote ça
arrive était suspendue dans la période
puisque la période est ici vous assure
la période était et est totalement
dédiée au soutien l'hôpital dans la
crise dans la gestion de la crise du
virus totalement dédiée au soutien des
soignants et le président de la
république le 23 mars dernier à mulhouse
a eu des mots qui sont très forts
d'ailleurs vous les avez rappelé vous
mêmes à savoir un grand plan
d'investissements revalorisation des
carrières reconnaissance de la santé
pour ce qu'elle apporte de merveilleux
dans notre société cela si vous
m'interrogez sur la méthode passe par
une concertation je pense qu'il est
indispensable que nous demandions à
celles et ceux qui font l'hôpital
aujourd'hui et qui sont applaudis par
les français ce qu'ils attendent de
l'hôpital et de leur outil de travail
pour aujourd'hui comme pour demain donc
mais il n'empêche que ça doit pas non
plus nous retarder dans notre capacité à
dire l'hôpital en retour de ce qui vous
a apporté ce qu'on veut que nous voulons
lieu aussi à lui aussi nous apporter
donc les choses monsieur
laurent sont très claires et je crois
que ce débat il va évidemment traversé
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale dans cette assemblée
comme à l'assemblée nationale et je suis
presque sûr qu'après une épidémie de
cette ampleur nous serons trouver des
voies de passage vers le vert un
consensus national peut-être pas entier
est totale mais je pense que la
direction que nous voulons pour
l'hôpital elle est très partagée sur
tous les bancs cette assemblée en tout
cas c'est ce que je reçois comme message
de la part de l'union nationale qui
s'est fait jour depuis le premier jour
de cette crise épidémique
la parole est à notre collègue jérôme
durain pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé le
président de la république a décrété
l'état de guerre et la mobilisation
générale contre le coronavirus des élus
de tous les partis se sont mobilisés
pour répondre aux besoins exprimés par
le personnel des hôpitaux et des ehpad
les pharmaciens les soignants libéraux
ses besoins étaient pour certains pas
satisfait par l'état des régions des
départements des communes se sont
démenés pour combler les manques eu
notamment masques
elles l'ont fait en informant l'état par
l'intermédiaire des préfets et des
agences régionales de santé
l'état a malheureusement pu donner
l'impression de ne pas être en capacité
d'accompagner l'action de chacun des
acteurs
un épisode malheureux a ainsi eu lieu
lors de la réception d'une livraison de
masques commandés par les régions
bourgogne franche comté grand test et
par l'état en effet l'armée a
réquisitionné sur le tarmac l'ensemble
de la commande
cette réquisition aurait pu être
comprise si elles avaient été annoncées
expliquer ou justifier
il n'en a rien été plusieurs autres cas
similaires au plan national renvoie aux
élus locaux un sentiment décourageant de
frustration voire d'inefficacité ceux
qui voient les masques dont ils ont
besoin partir vers d'autres territoires
le ressentent même comme une expression
de mépris à l'égard de leur propre
population
alors même que sur le terrain le
dialogue est bon entre l'état
territoriale et les élus comme entre les
élus eux mêmes l'état central donne
encore le sentiment d'improviser
faute d'avoir suffisamment anticipé et
de mal coordonner ses troupes préfet et
ars cette question de la confiance et la
coordination entre les acteurs est
primordial
nos besoins de masques ne vont pas
diminuer un nouveau changement de
doctrine concernant le port des masques
est attendue monsieur le ministre
allez vous transmettre et faire
appliquer des consignes claires pour que
l'état régule coordonne et ne parle que
d'une seule voix pour de la parole et
aux milices de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe castaner celui-ci oui
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous poser la
question de la difficulté
d'approvisionnement de masques sur le
marché mondial que nous connaissons mais
aussi sur les commandes qui sont portées
par les uns les autres et les
collectivités locales vous l'avez dit
ils prennent toute leur part dans notre
pays sur l'événement que vous évoquez
parce qu'il est important de partir de
la réalité de ce qui s'est passé à
l'aéroport de bâle mulhouse
il ya eu cette conséquence de la course
aux masques et le fait qu' un certain
nombre d'importateurs prennent des
commandes de différents interlocuteurs
qu'il s'agisse de l'état qu'il s'agisse
des collectivités locales dans le cas
particulier que vous évoquez il n'y a
pas eu de réquisition ni par l'armée ni
par qui que ce soit ait eu des commandes
des commandes légitime forte portée par
des collectivités locales et par l'état
et en particulier par là la rs de l'
agence régionale de santé de la région
du grand test
elle avait quand des 6 millions de
masques et elle attendait de cet
importateur 6 millions de masques
mais les livraisons n'ont pas été au
rendez vous comme elle était
initialement prévu et donc il ya une
première livraison de deux millions de
masques pour la rs et la rs a pris en
charge le déplacement et à plus de
distribuer largement les masques qui
était prévu puis l'importateur devait
livrer 4 millions de masques dimanche
dans un avion spécialement affrété à la
rs grand test est l'importateur avait
aussi pris des commandes de deux
collectivités locales la région
bourgogne franche comté et le
département des bouches du rhône au
moment de la livraison il n'y avait que
3 4 millions de masques qui étaient
disponibles et qui ont été du coup donné
en priorité en priorité pour les
personnels soignants de la région du
grand st chacune et chacun sait que ne
s'agit pas de concurrence dès lors qu'il
s'agissait de fournir en priorité les
personnels soignants de la région du
grand texte mme à travers
je voudrais réaffirmer je le ferai dans
quelques instants à nouveau sur une
question du président retailleau je
voudrais réaffirmer le fait qu'
évidemment il n'est pas question qu'il y
ait deux guerres de masse entre les
collectivités locales et l'état et que
nous devons tout faire pour travailler
main dans la main c'est le sens d
instruction que j'ai rappelé hier soir à
l'ensemble des préfets au dessus du rhin
istres pour cette réponse que nous le
contestons sur le terrain c'est que nous
travaillons bien dans notre région avec
l'état avec le préfet avec la grèce mais
c'est que les préfets ne se parlent pas
forcément les ars ne se parlent pas
forcément et que les ars et les préfets
n'échange pas toujours ensemble
que ce soit sur cette question des
masques ou sur d'autres questions donc
il ne s'agit pas d'un problème d'achat
d'approvisionnement mais de coordination
face au courant d'un virus nous avons
besoin d'une équipe soudée
elle est il nous faut un bon entraîneur
l'état merci la parole de notre collègue
joël guerriau pour le groupe des
indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre les français
confiné utilisent massivement le
numérique pour travailler à distance
pour faire leurs achats pour se divertir
ou encore pour échanger avec leurs
proches la géolocalisation peut
également être un outil pour traquer les
déplacements et endiguer la diffusion du
coït 19
tout cela pose des problèmes d'éthique
de liberté individuelle et aussi de
respect des données individuelles mais
cela soulève aussi un problème la
question de la souveraineté numérique en
france la situation actuelle révèle et
renforce notre dépendance aux gars
femmes
ces géants prennent une part de plus en
plus prépondérant dans notre économie
sans payer d'impôts à la hauteur de
leurs profits les entreprises françaises
souffrent pendant que ces géants gagne
des parts de marché il soit normal que
les entreprises qui bénéficient
finalement de cette crise contribuent
financièrement à aider celles qui en
pâtissent le confinement agit en réalité
comme le révélateur de notre faiblesse
dans l'approvisionnement d'équipements
comme ça vient d'être dit mais aussi en
médicaments mais aussi au niveau
de la maîtrise d'internet nous devons
penser cette crise comme une opportunité
de modifier notre modèle de
développement
trop dépendant d'autres dations dans des
domaines majeurs
comment comptez vous monsieur le
ministre bâtir la souveraineté française
et européenne en particulier dans le
domaine des hautes technologies et les
numériques a bien su mieux pour vous
répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état en charge du numérique monsieur
cédric oh merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur guerriau je ne sais
que vous dire si ce n'est que le
gouvernement et moi-même partageons bien
évidemment votre préoccupation et je ne
peux que m'interroger même inquiété
quand je vois que dans la période
l'ensemble des français mais également
les institutions ont massivement recours
aux outils numériques des entreprises
américaines et que même les institutions
l'état dès lors qu'il s'agit par exemple
de faire de la visioconférence décide
instantanément peut-être le cas ici
aussi d'aller sur une application
américaine qui certes marche très bien
mais pose énormément de questions et
donc je pense que ce que vous dites est
totalement infondée c'est d'ailleurs un
sujet qui intéresse beaucoup la haute
assemblée qui a missionné sur pied une
commission sur la souveraineté numérique
présidée par messieurs montaugé et
longuet c'est que la question de
l'émergence de champions numérique et
l'émergence de solutions numériques
françaises et rod européenne est au
coeur de l'indépendance et du respect
d'ailleurs des valeurs vous l'avez cité
de l'europe et de la france qui vient
quelque part corroborer ce qui a été la
stratégie de ce gouvernement depuis
trois ans parfois un peu raillé sous le
terme de start up née charme de dire que
faire émerger des champions du numérique
c'est indispensable
et d'ailleurs on le voit dans quelques
secteurs je pense à la télé médecine par
exemple où je pense lorsque l'éducation
nationale a nécessité de déployer son
espace numérique de travail sûrement
beaucoup plus d'élèves la capacité de
trouver des serveurs français a été
extrêmement appréciée nous avons
aujourd'hui cette entreprise qui sont
des licornes en france qui valent plus
d'un milliard d'euros 4 ont émergé dans
la dernière année en partie grâce à la
politique menée par le gouvernement mais
je pense que nous devons accélérer et
que la question que vous posez est
absolument essentiel dans l'après crise
nous ne sommes pas encore dans l'après
mais dans les éléments qui devons fonder
la réflexion économique et souveraine de
la france et de l'europe de l'après
crise c'est la capacité à travailler sa
souveraineté dans bien des domaines
sanitaire évidemment d'abord mais
également numérique
je gagne au lej merci monsieur le
ministre puisque je me réjouis que vous
partagez cette orientation est
d'ailleurs le fait d'avoir créé un
secrétariat au numérique nous permet
d'avoir cet espoir je le dis d'autant
plus qu'il ya aussi d'autres domaines et
la défense nationale en est un que nous
forces armées que nos police puisse
disposer d'outils qui leur permettent de
se prémunir contre une attaque
terroriste ou encore pour réagir par
rapport à des cyber attaques
je pense que c'est vraiment un domaine
où il faut absolument que nous gagnons
cette souveraineté et je j'ai confiance
dans le fait que nous puissions tous
ensemble et travailler et se créer un
nouveau modèle de développement
use à usage de notre pays et nous
permettent de de faire face à des crises
comme celle que nous vivons en toute
indépendance
merci la parole et au président philippe
bas pour le groupe l'est républicain
vers la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre j'ai deux questions la
première consigne concerne
l'organisation de notre pays pour faire
face à la crise
le premier mise l'état n'est pas seul
face au co vite 19 est d'abord tous les
français sans lesquelles le confinement
ne pourrait pas être efficace et il faut
saluer l'esprit de discipline
globalement dont ils font preuve
d'esprit de responsabilité individuelle
dans l'intérêt collectif
et puis il ya les collectivités
territoriales les maires qui assure la
continuité du service
aux habitants sont avec l écoute des
plus vulnérables fournissent aux
écoliers le matériel dont ils ont besoin
les départements qui ont mis à la
disposition de l'état les laboratoires
départementaux et interdépartementaux
pour les tests de dépistage mais qui
aussi s'occupe des collégiens des
personnes âgées et handicapées
les régions qui participent au fonds de
solidarité que vous avez mis en place et
c'est toute une harmonie qu'il faut
réussir à créer entre les différents
intervenants auxquels s'ajoutent les
initiatives philanthropiques elles aussi
nombreuses et la situation qu'a rappelé
tout à l'heure notre collègue du rhin
nous préoccupe tous il faut que vous
réussissiez absolument à ne pas
décourager l'initiative des régions et
des départements
et il n'ya pas que bourgogne franche
comté il ya d'autres régions d'autres
départements
il faut que ces initiatives soient bien
coordonné bien harmoniser que pour ceux
ci vous vous en donner les moyens
et je voudrais savoir comment vous allez
vous y prendre et puis à une question
très aiguë très immédiate une
préoccupation que nous partageons tout
celles de nos aînés celle de nos parents
et grands parents pour les plus jeunes
âgés et en particulier dans les maisons
de retraite médicalisées la commission
des affaires sociales a entendu ce matin
la présidente de la caisse nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie
nous constatons que dans de très
nombreuses maisons de retraite le
personnel n'a toujours pas en nombre
suffisant les masques dont il a besoin
pour éviter les contaminations et il est
très important que le gouvernement
accélère la mise à disposition de ces
personnels des équipements qui sont les
équipements indispensables pour faire
face aux risques d'épidémies mortifère
dans les maisons de retraite pour
répandre la parole à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
deux aspects dans votre question
l'aspect général de collaboration entre
l'état les collectivités territoriales
dans la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
et puis la question spécifique des
personnes âgées en situation de
dépendance est d'ailleurs d'être plus
généralement de toutes les personnes
fragiles accueillis dans des structures
collectives
je commence par le premier aspect de la
question pour dire que vous avez raison
de dire que dans une crise sanitaire
il ya bien sûr l'état mais il n'ya pas
que l'état il y à la nation il y a les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises et heureusement depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire on a vu à
côté de l'état souvent en bonne
intelligence avec l'état de très
nombreuses autres entités publiques ou
privées venir s'associer à l'effort
collectif venir s'engager dans l'effort
collectif
je parlais tout à l'heure du fonds de
solidarité
le fonds de solidarité au fond qu'est-ce
que c'est un réceptacle financier qui a
pour objectif d'accompagner ceux dé
celle des entreprises les plus petites
qui se trouvent confrontés à une
interruption complète de leurs activités
parcellaire de leur activité et donc à
une difficulté qui met en cause leur
existence même l'état bombe ce fonds il
l'a créée il verse le premier étage les
tâches automatiques c'est la dg fille
qui le fait à cela des entreprises les
assureurs notamment à hauteur de 200
millions sont venus participer à ce
dispositif ils l'ont fait volontairement
après que nous ayons discuter avec eux
et je les remercie car c'est très utile
d'autres entreprises parfois
discrètement sans l'annoncer mais parce
qu'elle considérait qu'il fallait
participer à cet effort ont également
abondé le fonds de solidarité et les
régions ont accepté de verser 250
millions d'euros et d'instruire avec
l'état le deuxième étage du fonds doit
permettre d'accompagner un peu plus
encore les entreprises qui se trouvent
dans une situation particulière aux plus
difficiles en fonction notamment d'une
appréciation régionale qui doit être
pouvoir qui doit être observé et est
mise en oeuvre voilà un exemple
on a beaucoup d'autres de collaboration
intelligente entre différentes entités
et notamment les collectivités
territoriales et l'état
mais il y en a mille autres les communes
ont très souvent remarquablement joué le
jeu de l'accompagnement des enfants des
soignants aux côtés de l'éducation
nationale dans certaines communes
complétant le dispositif ou le rendant
plus efficace dans d'autres inventant
des activités mettant en oeuvre des
activités périscolaires qui pouvaient là
encore être incroyablement précieuse
pour celles et ceux des soignants qui
avait besoin de faire garder leurs
enfants pour continuer à être tout à
leur tâche et notamment à l'hôpital
cette collaboration nous entendons la
chérir la préserver et la développer
c'est la raison pour laquelle lorsque je
reçois les responsables politiques je le
fais avec les présidents des grandes
associations d'élus de façon à ce que
chacune des strates importante des
collectivités territoriales soit informé
et dans toute la mesure du possible
associés s'agissant des personnes les
plus fragiles accueillis dans des
structures collectives nous avons c'est
là que se joue si j'ose dire la deuxième
bataille
la première bataille et hospitalière je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure en réponse au
président patriat la deuxième bataille
est celle qui se livre dans les ehpad et
dans les structures qui accueillent
notamment des personnes en situation de
handicap pour la gagner il faut
mobiliser des moyens il faut faire en
sorte de pouvoir tester
il faut faire en sorte de pouvoir
protéger il faut mettre en place une
logistique qui est très particulière qui
lie à plus de 7000 établissements sur
l'ensemble du territoire national qui
relève de cette logique le ministre des
solidarités de la santé a indiqué que sa
priorité c'était de développer les tests
notamment les tests virologiques dans
les ehpad dans les structures
collectives dont nous parlons
pour pouvoir le faire dans de bonnes
conditions il faut évidemment pouvoir
s'appuyer sur les laboratoires
départementaux vous les avez vous même
évoqué nous avons et ça n'était pas si
simple
je sais que certains se sont émus du
temps qu'il a fallu pour lever les
limites
la vérité c'est que ça n'était pas si
simple parce que les limites elles ont
été posées par des normes
ce n'est pas le gouvernement actuel qui
les ai inventées ces normes et elles
n'ont pas été inventés pour ennuyer le
monde l'ont été parce qu'elle
garantissait un niveau de sécurité ou
bon voilà ça arrive et c'est bien je ne
critique pas le mais pour l'élever
croyez moi c'est parfois un effort bref
je passe sur le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
possible et c'est tant mieux
nous allons donc pouvoir nous appuyer
sur ces structures de la même façon que
nous allons nous appuyer
parent travaille en bonne intelligence
menée par le ministre et par
l'association des départements de france
sur les structures départementales pour
collecter les tests et ensuite procéder
à leur analyse c'est donc là aussi un
travail en bonne intelligence qui se
construit il se construit dans des
circonstances uniques véritablement dans
notre histoire
j'allais dire récente même assez ancien
mais il est en train de se construire et
il se passe bien et il doit se passer de
mieux en mieux
quel que soit le niveau de collectivité
nous devons gagner cette bataille et
nous ne la gagneront pas seule personne
ne la gagnera sol il faut donc faire en
sorte que cette intelligence des
territoires cette coordination des
bonnes volontés et des compétences
puissent effectuer dans les meilleures
conditions je sais que ça et là il y a
des frottements
je sais que ça et là il ya des
différences d'approché
ça n'est pas anormal et au fond ça ne
nous surprend pas l'important c'est que
chacun y mette du sien et qu'on dépasse
ses difficultés pour obtenir le résultat
recherché
mais si la parole est maintenant aux
présidents vincent delahaye pour le
groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
à situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
la crise sanitaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui va déboucher sur une crise
économique sans précédent dans leur
grande majorité les français n'ont pas
encore conscience
anesthésiés par le confinement et la
peur du virus mais la catastrophe
économique à venir entraînera de graves
conséquences sociales
le gouvernement a pris la mesure de la
gravité de la situation en lançant un
premier plan de soutien économique
délais de paiement déchéance sociale et
fiscale rééchelonnement de crédits
bancaires mobilisation
pays -france chômage partiel simplifiée
renforcée parmi les mesures les plus
notables figurent la possibilité pour
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
les travailleurs indépendants et les
micro entrepreneurs de différer le
paiement de leurs charges sociales ou de
leurs impôts directs
cette mesure a offert une respiration
salutaire à ses bénéficiaires letten
nécessaire elle nous apparaît
aujourd'hui insuffisante
la perspective d'un décaissement
important de ces sommes dans le futur
est une épée de damoclès suspendue au
dessus de structures dans la pérennité
même est menacée
même avec des facilités de paiement
nombre d'entre elles ne pourront pas
payer ses charges reportées
n'ayant n'ayant eu aucune recette
pendant la période de confinement et ne
disposant d'aucune réserve aux marches
financière dans leurs activités
monsieur le ministre de l'économie en
commission des affaires économiques a
confié réfléchir à l'effacement de
certains prélèvements obligatoires pour
les indépendants les tpe et certaines
pme
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous le
confirmer ici
si oui nous sommes bien conscients qu'un
tel dispositif devrait être strictement
encadré pour éviter fraudes abus effet
d'aubaine qu'elle pourrait être selon
vous les critères à retenir pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'un dégrèvement de sa dette
sociale et fiscale je vous remercie pour
vous répondre la parole qu'à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances la manière
une hache et vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur de là et vous
l'avez dit nous avons mis en place dans
le cadre de cette crise économique un
plan massif un plan d'accompagnement qui
visait en premier lieu à alléger
soutenir la trésorerie des entreprises
pensent qu'un dépôt de bilan
c'est un problème de trésorerie à la
base et c'était la première étape
nécessaire immédiate à mettre en oeuvre
tout de suite c'est ce que nous avons
fait avec le report des charges sociales
et fiscales c'est aujourd'hui pour le
relais report fiscal
plus de cinquante quatre mille demandes
pour 45000 entreprises et 3,2 milliards
d'euros de trésorerie
apporter en creux à ces entreprises etc
pour les reports social 1,8 million de
professionnels pour 4,7 milliards
d'euros
donc on voit la mesure est massive elle
est accompagnée du fonds de solidarité
des entreprises dont on commence à voir
arriver les paiements sur les comptes en
banque des indépendants et elle est
accompagnée de cette mesure de
trésorerie qui permet aux entreprises
qui le demandent et qui remplissent les
critères de bénéficier d'un crédit de
trésorerie représentant 25% de son
chiffre d'affaires annuel
ce premier temps il doit être complété
doit être complétée au mois d'avril pour
poursuivre cet effort il doit être
également complété en anticipant qu'elle
sera le point de sortie de la crise car
l'accompagnement ne sera probablement
pas de même dimension
si la reprise ou le retour à la normale
et qu'est ce que voudrait dire la
normale ce fait fin avril famé ou prend
du temps dans la durée car nous ne
sommes pas le seul pays atteints et
comme vous le savez très bien nos
économies est en tout très liés
les la consommation mondiale ne va pas
repartir au quart de tour de même que
les chaînes logistiques sont durement
éprouvé donc oui nous réfléchissons à
abattre des dégrèvements c'est
aujourd'hui possible sur demande c'est
assez peu utilisées parce que je pense
que tout le monde est dans un état
d'attenté regarde comment faire mais ce
sera examiné de même que nous le faisons
généralement pour les entreprises en
difficulté de revoir les échéanciers et
d'abattre des
démont fiscaux je vous remercie monsieur
le président de la merci madame un
ministre de nous avoir confirmé que le
principe d'une annulation de charges
ciblées sur certaines activités
certaines structures étaient envisagés
par le gouvernement
nous comprenons que le cadre de cette
éventuelle annulation reste à définir
quels secteurs d'activité quel type
d'entreprise quelle période prise en
compte
parlementaires et gouvernement pourrait
envisager une réflexion commune pour
définir ces critères comme toujours le
sénat est prête à contribuer à cette
indispensable réflexion
si le goff la parole le pr collègue
philippe pemezec pour le groupe l'est
républicain ce le président mes chers
collègues dames et messieurs les
ministres se prémunit ce n'est qu'après
l'annoncent du confinement le 17 mars
que le gouvernement a pris un certain
nombre de mesures pour protéger des
entreprises françaises à défaut d'avoir
su faire face aux premiers assauts de la
guerre sanitaire et à ormoy retenu la
leçon économique et financière de la
crise de 2008 d'abord une aide
forfaitaire est apparemment généreuse
qui a été mise en place pour les tpe
indépendant et micro entrepreneurs via
le fonds de solidarité
mais cette mesure est insuffisante de
nombreuses tpe
malheureusement devront mettre la clé
sous la porte imaginez un restaurateur
sans chiffre d'affaires qui doit payer
ses factures et ses charges des tpe ne
l'oublions pas représente 3 millions 300
mille entreprises c'est-à-dire 95 % du
tissu économique
elle emploie 20 % des salariés en france
elle sur le coeur qui fait battre et
respirer nos communes alors monsieur le
prix mini si les banques vous prennent
vous elles ne prennent plus au téléphone
aux artisans ni nos commerçants et si
elle les lâches ce sera un abîme dans la
fracture territoriale alors j'ai trois
questions à l'heure où nous sommes au
milieu de la tempête
quelles sont les mesures supplémentaires
concrètes efficaces et application
immédiate que vous comptez prendre pour
éviter d'ajouter à la crise sanitaire
une catastrophe économique financière et
sociale deuxièmement quand utiliser vous
votre poids pour faire pression sur les
banques et sur les assureurs
je rappelle que les banques ont été
sauvées par l'état c'est à dire par le
contribuable lors de la crise de 2008
serait peut-être normal que les banques
à l'heure tous le retour fasse un effort
enfin troisièmement vous avez dit à
l'instant que les communes joué le jeu
ça m'a frappé cette phrase elle ne joue
pas les communes elles sont sur le
terrain elles sont font preuve au
quotidien de leur efficacité
parce que c'est elle qui sont la face à
la crise on peut pas dire que l'état lui
fasse preuve toujours de cette même île
est efficacité j'espère donc après cette
crise au sortir de cette crise on votera
une loi nouvelle de décentralisation
pour donner enfin à ceux qui ont cette
capacité exhorté le pouvoir de le faire
au quotidien correctement comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état aux prémices de l'économie et des
finances vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
sénateurs
d'abord vous l'avez dit nous sommes aux
côtés des entreprises nous n'avons pas
attendu je crois que l'état a fait
montre de sa très grande réactivité
grâce aussi à la représentation
nationale qui a très vite voter les
mesures que nous lui avons proposé et
aujourd'hui la trésorerie est en route
vers les entreprises elles le sont
particulièrement vers les tpe puisque
vous le savez le fonds de solidarité
pour les entreprises c'est aujourd'hui
demain après demain que les 1500 euros
arrive sur le compte en banque de tout
de tout ces entreprises ça c'est
efficace concret pertinent me
semble-t-il
ensuite il faut bien sûr aller plus loin
parce que les tpe sont confrontés à des
difficultés en face à leur absence de
chiffre d'affaires doivent faire face à
des charges qu'avons nous fait nous
avons repris point point ces charges
face à la masse salariale des mesures de
chômage partiel face aux problèmes de
paiement des loyers des mesures pour
accompagner les bailleurs et faire en
sorte qu'il repousse aussi ses paiements
de loyer et peut-être négocié des
abattements face aux factures
d'électricité d'eau des mesures
spécifiques pour faire en sorte que
justement les très petites entreprises
n'est pas à payer immédiatement ses
factures face à problématique
d'assureurs puisque vous le
pointe et non seulement les assureurs
participe à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros
et eux ne croit savoir qu'ils ont versé
leur argent aux fonds de solidarité des
entreprises il est vrai que nous sommes
nombreux à y participer nous sommes très
heureux de pouvoir accueillir les autres
collectivités locales mais cet argent il
est arrivé mais s'ils ont également
accepté de repousser le paiement des
primes sans remettre en cause
l'intégrité des contrats donc ça c'est
un effort solidaire manifeste important
et nous allons continuer et continuer
spécifiquement visant ces très petites
entreprises car moi je passe beaucoup de
temps avec alger était encore deux
heures au téléphone avec l'ensemble des
fédérations de commerçants pour pointer
les assureurs crédit les problématiques
dans les banques
les soucis avec les bailleurs et faire
en sorte que la médiation du crédit soit
sur des territoires
un service d'état que la médiation des
entreprises soit sur le territoire un
service d'état et que chacun soit
mobilisée à leurs côtés merci madame le
ministre la parole est notre collègue
jean claude tissot pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
je tenais tout d'abord à saluer le
courage et l'engagement des personnels
qui depuis le début d'épidémie sont
allés travailler avec la peur au ventre
parfois trop longtemps en effet elles
sont ils ont manqué des moyens de
protection alors que ces professionnels
sont depuis plusieurs années confrontée
à des difficultés structurelles dû au
manque de moyens financiers et humains
ils ont su trouver les ressources pour
faire face de manière admirable à cette
crise j'espère sincèrement monsieur le
ministre que lorsque viendra le jour
d'après on s'empressera pas dans
n'oubliez de les oublier
vous avez annoncé ce lundi 6 avril le
lancement d'une vaste opération de
dépistage dans ces établissements c'est
qu'une mesure que je salue elle
permettra de mieux gérer la situation
l'une des problématiques à traiter en
priorité et celle de l'accompagnement
des personnes en fin de vie
je reprendrai les mots du psychiatre
michel debout professeur émérite de
médecine légale qui explique que la
présence des membres de la famille dans
les derniers instants d'un proche est
tout à la fois la condition
psychologique affective et émotionnelle
pour permettre à la personne âgée de
mourir dans la sérénité et la condition
pour la famille de ne pas ressentir
qu'elle a abandonné une dernière fois
son parent ils redoutent ainsi que
beaucoup de ces familles ne présentent
une fois la crise sanitaire passer des
étapes deuil pathologique qui viendront
pour une période longue dégrader leur
vie psychique et relationnel se pose de
la même manière la question de la prise
en charge des soignants qui au lendemain
de la crise auront de la peine à être
prise en charge
je voudrais aussi dire un mot des agents
des services mortuaires dernier maillon
de la chaîne du chemin il demande à ce
titre pouvoir comme tous les soignants
bénéficier de toutes les protections
face au virus
comme le souligne très justement le
professeur debout notre humaine
condition se construit depuis la nuit
des temps sur le fait que nous soyons la
seule espèce vivante qui enterre ses
morts
cette place donnée aux morts permettent
de les relier aux vivants et de nous et
de construire avec eux la chaîne
ininterrompue de l'humanité aussi
monsieur le ministre je voulais savoir
si vous envisagez de pouvoir rapidement
rendre possible la présence d'au moins
un membre de la famille aux côtés du
mourant en fournissant bien sûr les
moyens de protection nécessaires face au
risque infectieux
merci pour vous répondre la parole
d'état celui des solidarités et de la
santé smith avait la parole monsieur le
sénateur jean claude tissot merci pour
votre question traite de l'humanisme
avec lequel on affronte la fin de vie
dans des conditions déjà difficile en
ehpad déjà très difficile et près de
cent mille personnes qui décèdent chaque
année en ehpad
c'est près de 300 personnes par jour qui
décèdent dans les ehpad de notre pays
qui est bien souvent la dernière demeure
des personnes qui y résident pour vous
répondre
monsieur le sénateur ce que vous
souhaitez dans votre question est déjà
possible dans le droit j'ai autorisé
nous avons autorisé la visite d'une
personne d'un proche dans les derniers
instants de la vie des résidents en
ehpad comme un d'ailleurs un
établissement hospitalier en fixant des
conditions de dire que vous dessinez
vous même à travers votre question
équipement adéquat pour ne pas faire
rentrer un virus le virus dans
l'établissement
même un parcours d
et au sein de l'établissement avec une
chambre particulière lorsque c'est
possible pour permettre d'éviter tout
risque de contamination liée à l'entrée
de personnes au sein d'établissements
c'est autorisé et c'est normal je ne dis
pas que cela est simplement simple à
réaliser et à mettre en place mais les
directeurs d'établissements ont la
possibilité encore une fois c'était pas
une application cédant peut-être
l'application du droit j'imagine que le
problème vous a été soulevée sur ds une
situation particulière peut-être pouvez
venir vous revenir vers mon cabinet je
m'engage à contacter chaque ehpad dans
lesquels la situation ce serait
difficile où les faire contacter
peut-être je travaille beaucoup en lien
avec les fédérations des pas de services
à domicile et que je remercie pour leur
action déterminée encore une fois n'y a
pas de blocage ni les sites hâtif ni
réglementaire au niveau national sur ces
questions et si monsieur le ministre
la parole est aux questeurs vincent
capo-canellas ce pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
solidarités de la protection de
l'enfance depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire nous alertons avec la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat et sa présidente annick vision jeu
la recrudescence des violences
intrafamiliales engendrés par le
confinement violences faites aux femmes
et aux enfants
le gouvernement a très vite annoncer des
mesures pour répondre à l'urgence de la
situation
mais on sait que ces violences faites
aux femmes comme aux enfants sont bien
sûr aggravée par le confinement jeu
ministre avez vous à ce stade une
première évaluation de l'ampleur du
phénomène notamment en direction des
normands qui ont bien sûr plus de mal
encore à donner l'alerté
nous savons que pour répondre
efficacement la détresse de ces femmes
et ces enfants en danger chez eux
il est essentiel de leur donner les
moyens de se signaler et de le faire
depuis leur domicile c'est pourquoi il
convient que les forces de l'ordre à qui
nous tenons à rendre un hommage puisse
assurer le suivi des mains courantes et
des plaintes est ce bien le cas
à compter de l'état les conseils
départementaux joue un rôle essentiel
dans la protection de l'enfance et la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes comme aux enfants comment les
services de l'état cour donne t-il avec
les acteurs de terrain leur action et
comment et assurer la prise en charge
des victimes et la permanence des
structures d'accueil qu'avez vous prévu
à destination dé constater partout
acteur majeur dans la lutte contre les
violences seule la fin du confinement
dévoilera l'ampleur des violences
intrafamiliales
les services de protection l'anticipent
t-il dans l'immédiat vous annonciez avec
votre collègue madame icap à un million
d'euros à destination des associations
quels sont les critères d'attribution
pour vous répandre la parole tout
secrétaire d'état auprès de louise des
solidarités de la santé tu adrien taquet
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur monsieur le questeur notre
mobilisation a tous notre vigilance à
tous est à la hauteur de notre
inquiétude
et quand je dis à tous et bien
évidemment l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement lors sont des services de
l'état mais aussi les associations les
travailleurs sociaux auxquels je veux
rendre hommage ici et bien évidemment
les départements et les communes de la
même façon
dès l'instauration du confinement nous
avons fait en sorte la priorité était
que les dispositifs d'alert puisse
fonctionner façon efficace durant cette
période là nous avons adapté le 39 19
aux contraintes du du confinement avec
la livraison notamment de trente
téléphones portables nous avons
déclenché le plan de continuité du 119
le numéro de l'enfance en danger vous
avez aujourd'hui une trentaine
d'intervenants qui peuvent répondre 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 nous avons
renforcé l'information sur la plate
forme de signalement arrêtons les
violences point gouv.fr nous avons mis
en place avec les départements les plans
de continuité des cellules
départementale de recueil des
informations préoccupantes les fameuses
script et nous suivons la situation en
lien avec le giped le 119 qui est en
lien avec avec ses cellules nous avons
enfin avec la garde des sceaux a assuré
la permanence pour les audiences
urgentes pour mineurs et la prise
d'ordonnancé de protection pour les
femmes et les enfants quand nécessaire
avec bien évidemment le maintien des
comparutions immédiates pour les auteurs
et puis par ailleurs nous avons des
multiplier les canaux de signalements
vous l'avez évoqué la question de la
parole en particulier pour les enfants
est particulièrement prégnante en temps
normal et plus encore en période de
confinement nous avons depuis jeudi
dernier mis en place un formulaire de
signalement en ligne sur le site
internet du 119 allô 119 points gouv.fr
en moins d'une semaine ce sont plus de
130 signalements qui ont pu être porté
par ce canal nous avons mis en place un
système d' alerte avec marine schiappa
castaner pour les femmes et les enfants
victimes de violence conjugale dans les
pharmacies dans les centres commerciaux
nous avons adapté le 114 pour que les
signalements puisse être fait par sms et
sachez que quatre enfants on signalait
des violences par ce biais là deux ont
donné lieu à des interventions urgentes
des services de police et enfin pour
finir de répondre à votre question pour
soutenir différentes initiatives la
secrétaire d'état a effectivement décidé
de mobiliser une enveloppe d'un million
d'euros qui se répartit en trois grands
volets soutien l'hébergement des femmes
victimes de violence soutien
l'hébergement des auteurs de violences
conjugales et enfin soutien des
associations nationales et de terrain
deux minutes ne suffisent pas à ce que
nous puissions partager ensemble
l'ensemble des défis auxquels nous
sommes confrontés en cette ère de
confinement ni l'ensemble des mesures
que nous avons conclus depuis ces trois
semaines mais je crois que nous aurons
l'occasion de continuer de poursuivre
cette discussion la semaine prochaine à
l'occasion d'une audition auprès de la
délégation des droits des femmes que
j'aurai le plaisir de faire merci merci
monsieur le ministre des éléments que
vous avez bien voulu nous nous
communiquer nous partageons la
mobilisation est simplement notre
message c'est de rappeler que la
protection de l'enfance comme celle des
femmes doit être évidemment
spécifiquement assuré en cette période
avec une vigilance toute particulière
je remercie monsieur questeur la parole
être recollés gravier pour la réunion
administrative des sénateurs de figurant
sur la liste d'oka gros vous avez la
parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse quand même à monsieur le
premier ministre
la vie continue il n'y a aucune raison
mise à part pour les populations
fragilisées de modifier nos habitudes de
sortie cette phrase à un mois quasiment
jour pour jour est allée du président de
la république emmanuel macron à propos
de la crise du coc vie de 19 en une
phrase voilà résumé tout l'impréparation
et l'incompétence de l'état
et ça n'est pas une surprise depuis nos
compatriotes découvrez subissent la
litanie de vos mensonges car vous avez
menti
et vous saviez vous saviez depuis le 11
janvier quand agnès buzyn a prévenu le
président de la république et l'ensemble
de votre gouvernement vous saviez et
vous avez choisi de mentir vous avez
menti et les français sont morts le 18
février le ministre de la santé olivier
véran déclaré que la france était prête
le 26 février jérôme salomon directeur
général de la santé a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de sujet de pénurie concernant
les masques le 20 mars
c'est laurent nunez qui a refusé de
reconnaître le manque de masques mais
alors pourquoi jérôme simplement at il
affirmé en privé quatre jours plus tôt
je le cite les stocks de masques sont
limitées et on en cherche partout
pourquoi le 5 avril christophe castaner
a appelé les français à donner leur
masque aux hôpitaux
vous avez vous même monsieur le premier
ministre a affirmé le 13 mars que porter
un masque ne servait à rien
la réalité c'est que vous avez menti sur
les masques pour gagner du temps sachant
pertinemment que les stocks stratégiques
avaient disparu depuis des années et que
donc la france n'avait plus conséquence
aujourd'hui la préfète de la région
grand-est réquisitionne les 6 millions
de masques destinés aux personnels
soignants des bouches-du-rhône et vous
avait réquisitionné les 4 millions de
masques commandés par la région
bourgogne franche comté
cela vire à l'anarchie vous avez même
réussi à faire voler en éclats l'unité
nationale incapable de prévoir vous êtes
incapable de protéger la population et
si les français sont en réanimation
n'en déplaise aux sinistres préfet de
police de paris c'est parce que votre
gouvernement n'a pas su pas pu ou pas
voulu les protéger tous ses drames vous
êtes vous en étaient responsables
et peut-être demain serait vous reconnu
coupable alors ma question la voici
pensez vous monsieur le premier ministre
que vos mensonges successifs relève de
la cour de justice de la république pour
vous répondre la parole est à monsieur
verrons je rappelle que ici la parole et
l'hymne la mesure fait aussi partie de
la tradition du sénat
monsieur le sénateur ravier vous poser
une question à laquelle nous sommes les
derniers à pouvoir répondre
par contre j'ai une question à vous
poser
monsieur ravier pensez vous demander ma
démission comme ministre des solidarités
la santé comme madame marine le pen
avait demandé la démission de madame
roselyne bachelot alors ministre de la
santé parce qu'elle avait commandé je
cite trop de masques je vous remercie
merci je vais maintenant levé la séance
merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci madame et messieurs les ministres
prochaines séances le mercredi 15 avril
à 15 heures pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement la séance
est levée
[Musique]
voilà cette séance de questions de
contrôle au sénat entièrement consacrée
à la question du coronavirus s'achève
donc sur cette réponse très brève un
presque laconique de olivier véran aux
sénateurs stéphane ravier qui réclamait
donc sa démission
voilà pour cette séance qui sinon a été
consacrée à onze questions très variées
qui sont allées bien de l'hôpital public
à la souveraineté numérique en passant
par la gestion des masques au début
notamment de cette séance le premier
ministre edouard philippe s'est exprimé
il s'est exprimé à deux reprises il a
notamment répondu à la question du
président du groupe de la république en
marche françois patriat qui lui
demandait de faire un bilan de
l'épidémie est à cette question il a
répondu qu'il s'était plus tôt félicité
de la gestion en tout cas dans les
hôpitaux je vous propose tout de suite
d'écoutés
et bien la réponse du premier ministre
qui a ouvert cette séance de questions
d'actualité
nous sommes au moment où nous parlons à
un moment de l'épidémie où le nombre
d'augmentations le nombre d'admissions
en service de réanimation qui donc l'
indicateur essentiel que nous suivons à
ce stade est en ralentissement
il progresse encore
mais avec un une progression qui est
désormais très lente très lente
nous avons dépassé les 7000 cas en
réanimation malades du cofide plus de
7000 cas c'est du jamais vu
j'avais eu sept mille personnes en
service de réanimation à cause de la
même maladie en france et nous avons
jusqu'à présent réussi à pouvoir
accueillir dans les services de
réanimation suffisamment de malades
tous les malades ont cassé vers
l'élément qui laisse entrevoir peut-être
et vous remarquez que je suis prudent
monsieur président patriat peut-être un
peu d'espoir c'est que cette progression
se ralentit au point que peut-être nous
arrivons à quelque chose qui
ressemblerait un plateau encore je dis
les choses prudemment quelque chose qui
ressemblerait un plateau c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
si ça se confirme voilà pour cette
réponse du premier ministre qui a donc
ouvert le bal des questions tout à
l'heure ses questions de contrôle sur le
corps en un virus tout à l'heure et bien
adrien taquet également et bien vous
avez été interrogés interrogé sur la
question des violences intrafamiliales
qui bien sûr est bien focalise aussi
l'attention cette période d'épidémie
coronavirus est ce que pour vous il y a
eu et bien une explosion des chiffres en
la matière qui a donné avez-vous au là
dessus alors écoutez on constate aussi
bien sur les violences faites aux femmes
que sur les violences faites aux enfants
effectivement une évolution des chiffres
marlène schiappa la secrétaire d'état et
christophe castaner ont eu l'occasion de
le dire un plus de 35% d'interventions
pour des faits de violences conjugales
ces dernières semaines et nous venons
d'avoir nous les derniers chiffres
s'agissant des violences faites aux
enfants sur les appels aux 119
je rappelle le numéro de l'enfance en
danger le 119 qui est gratuit et anonyme
nous avons sur les trois dernières
semaines de confinement par rapport aux
trois précédentes semaines une
augmentation de 20% des appels alors on
peut se dire c'est qu'il ya plus de
violence mais aussi on peut se dire
qu'on a réussi
c'est ce à quoi nous travaillons à
libérer la parole de l'enfant on imagine
bien que pour les femmes comme pour les
enfants être dans ce confinement dans
cette promiscuité ou parfois le bourreau
se trouve dans la pièce d'à côté il peut
être difficile d'appeler c'est la raison
pour laquelle et marlène schiappa à
christophe castaner et moi même avons
par ailleurs démultiplier les canaux de
signalement tout à l'heure vous avez
aussi été interrogé sur la somme qui
était attribué en plus en cette période
d'épidémie 1 million d'euros est ce que
c'est suffisant ou va exactement cet
argent comment est-il fléché leur écoute
et effectivement marlène schiappa
annoncé avoir débloqué une somme d'un
million d'euros à la fois pour soutenir
et permettre de financement financé par
don de l'hébergement d'urgence pour les
femmes victimes de violence de
l'hébergement aussi pour les auteurs
parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison que les
victimes que sont les femmes est souvent
leurs enfants dans plus de 80% des cas
subissent une sorte de double peine
c'est à dire elles seront à la fois
victimes de violence est par ailleurs
ils doivent quitter le domicile familial
pour échapper à leurs bourreaux donc il
faut bien que ce soit le bourreau qui
qu'ils soient extraits de la cellule et
du foyer familial
et puis par ailleurs cette somme ira
aussi pour soutenir les associations
nationales de terrain dont on voit bien
et on les en remercie et je veux ici les
saluer que ça soit sur la violence faite
aux femmes est de la même façon sur les
violences faites aux enfants qui ont
déployé des moyens supplémentaires en
cette période là et donc nous voulons
les soutenir financièrement
ça va être le cas dans les prochains
jours aussi je vais faire des annonces
s'agissant des associations de lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
et qui est de soutien à la parentalité
adrien taquet autres secteurs pour
laquelle c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui l'aide sociale à l'enfance
qui est plutôt sur la responsabilité et
des départements on sait qu'il ya par
exemple un second d'enfants qui sont
hébergés à l'hôtel etc
quelles sont les difficultés qui vous
sont remontés aujourd'hui et quel
encadrement est prévu pour ces enfants
bon alors il nous faudrait un peu plus
que tel que quelques minutes pour
évoquer ce sujet là car là aussi comme
dans le cercle familial
laissez les sujets les défis sont
nombreux ne sut suivons la situation de
très près avec l'ensemble des acteurs
les départements évidemment vous l'avez
évoqué je leur ai écrit il ya de cela
deux semaines et demie pour que nous
posions ensemble un cadre national
respect d'un certain nombre de principes
ces acteurs de terrain dis-je le
problème c'est que ça dépend aussi en
fonction des départements et les
départements qui sont très présentes
d'autres avec lesquels c'est beaucoup
plus diffuse avez raison c'est le 40
tonnes normal c'est souvent une critique
légitime que l'on entend en temps de
crise vous avez raison il ya nécessité
d'avoir un pilotage commun une
coordination encore plus forte je pense
qu'il ya une vraie attente de la part
des associations évidemment mais aussi
de la part des départements ils
s'étendent et cet esprit là que nous
travaillons depuis trois semaines moi
j'ai émis des fiches consignes pour
donner des repères des règles aux
différents acteurs de la protection
enfant j'ai écrit au département je
m'entretiens demain avec le président
bussereau président de l'association des
départements de france et je vais devoir
bientôt vous quitter car j'ai mon mât
visioconférence bon mach conférence
téléphonique plutôt hebdomadaire avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la protection
de l'enfance toutes les semaines
ensemble nous passons en revue les
différents sujets question de
d'absentéisme pour des raisons légitimes
que l'on comprend des travailleurs
sociaux qui peut poser des problèmes
d'encadrement vous avez parlé d'un
certain bruit enfants dans les hôtels
qu'il faut suivre plus particulièrement
nous faisons en sorte que tel soit le
cas bref beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets
qui donnerait lieu à d'autres à d'autres
échanges plus nombreux une petite
question précise certains demandé à
avoir accès parmi ces encadrants et bien
même dispositif que les personnels
soignants pour pouvoir garder leurs
enfants
jusqu'ici cela n'a pas été possible est
ce que une porte peut s'ouvrir et bien
écoutez je m'en excuse mais vous êtes
mal renseigné puisqu'en réalité c'est
possible depuis quinze jours encore
voilà effectivement vous avez raison
l'accès à l'école pour les enfants des
personnels soignants a été instaurée dès
le départ et
avec jean-michel bancaire et je tiens à
le remercier ici dès la seconde semaine
de confinement nous avons étendu ce
dispositif à l'ensemble des personnels
de la protection de l'enfant de façon
assez large travailleurs sociaux mais
aussi professionnels de la pmi par
exemple où les assistants familiaux
encore et ça a permis quasiment du jour
au lendemain de retrouver à peu près 20%
de des forces vives et que je souhaite
ici à une fois encore remercier pour
leur engagement auprès des auprès des
enfants
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes
questions va prendre votre place est
bien le président du groupe l air au
sénat bruno retailleau bruno retailleau
bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions une première question d'abord
sur et bien cette application sur
laquelle on commence à voir quelques
détails qui ont été donnés par olivier
ferrand par cédric haut dans le
quotidien le monde aujourd'hui
cette application stop qu'ovide on irait
vers du traçage numérique pour l'instant
le gouvernement reste très prudent dans
ce qu'il dit mais est ce que vous vous y
êtes favorable pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
ce que j'ai compris c'est qu'il
s'agissait d'ailleurs d'une application
d'alert pour avertir les gens qui
auraient pu croiser quelqu'un qui serait
contaminée qu'elle fonctionne sur une
technologie très peu intrusive
mais surtout que elle fonctionne aussi
sur la base du volontariat moi je pense
que aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
meurent aujourd'hui on est confiné
cette liberté d'aller et venir et les
restes la fin elle est restreinte
puisque nous sommes encore une fois dans
cette situation de confinement et donc
il faut écarter aucune modalité pour la
sortie de ce confinement pour la santé
aussi public de nos concitoyens il ya
quelques garanties
néanmoins à apporter notamment en
matière d'efficacité parce que vous
savez que aucune aucune application
numérique ne peut être utile si vous
n'avez pas suffisamment de masques
si vous ne généralisez pas le port des
masques et si vous ne dépiste et pas de
façon massive donc ça sert à rien de
partir trop vite sur ce genre de
réflexion si les solutions basiques de
protection de la population ne sont pas
remplies justement tout à l'heure il ya
eu plusieurs questions sur la gestion
des masques par le gouvernement ce que
vous avez été satisfait par la réponse
du gouvernement qui dit
priorise les attributions de masques
notamment été question des masques qui
ont été réquisitionnés au détriment de
certaines régions notamment et bien la
région bourgogne franche comté
tout à l'heure et bien christophe
castaner a dit il n'est pas question
qu'il y ait une guerre des masques est
ce que c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais
évidemment mais mais quelle est la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons les collectivités des régions
des départements des villes des communes
se sont lancés dans la commande de
masques pourquoi parce qu'il y avait pas
de masques y avait une pénurie de
masques
parce qu grosso modo l'état commander
mais ne parvenait pas ni à prévoir ni à
faire venir les masques en france il en
fallait pour les ehpad
il en fallait pour les services de soins
à domicile dead à domicile et donc les
collectivités ont voulu entreprend et
heureusement
heureusement qu'elle en fait une action
complémentaire à l'état et sans négocier
sans se concerter sans rien expliquer
dans la nouvelle aquitaine mais aussi
dans l'est mais aussi dans les bouches
du rhône au sud il ya eu ces
réquisitions
je pense que ça n'est pas une façon de
faire et je demande à ce que l'état
mettre bon ordre et qui est beaucoup
plus de liens entre l'action de l'état
et l'action des collectivités
territoriales est-ce que vous jugez que
l'état donc voulu dénoncer l'état a mal
agi dans ces différents cas de figure
lui qui dit qu'il priorisant qu'il a
aussi attribué les masques là où il
était le plus nécessaire dans les
régions en tension mais écoutez
évidemment moi moi dans ma région des
pays de la loire on a été une des
premières régions à commander on a
commandé par exemple dans un premier
temps un million cinq cent mille masques
qui va définir les priorités
on se repose sur la rs donc on joue le
jeu
parce que je demande c'est que l'état
joue le jeu la question que je pose
simplement c'est que si l'état doit
réquisitionner les masques de commandes
des collectivités
c'est donc bien que l'état manque
toujours de minces car pourquoi les
collectivités parviennent acheminer des
masques sur le sol de la république et
que l'état n'y parviendrais pas c'est
aussi une question qu'il faut poser ou
jugé qu il ya eu un changement de
doctrine du côté du gouvernement sur le
port du masque
certains disent eh bien finalement il a
échangé il a changé de doctrine et il a
dit au début que ce n'était pas
nécessaire tout simplement parce qu'il
n'y avait pas les stocks qui était
nécessaire pour l'ensemble de la
population
évidemment évidemment on a toutes les
déclarations qui montrent que
vraiment changé de pied tout simplement
parce que la stratégie de la crise de la
gestion de crise a été inspiré par la
pénurie beaucoup plus plupart des bonnes
pratiques et aujourd'hui petit à petit
on vient
un port généralisé pour demain du masque
évidemment une dernière question bruno
retailleau dans l'actualité
eh bien on a appris aujourd'hui le
limogeage du directeur de la rs du grand
est qui avait eu des propos sur le fait
qu'il maintenait la trajectoire sur les
suppressions de postes au chu de nancy
donc il ya eu son limogeage qui a été
acté ce matin en conseil des ministres
est ce que c'est pour vous une bonne
chose
et est ce que ça montre qu'il faut
arrêter les suppressions postes surtout
qu'il n'avait pas parlé au bon moment
moi je me prononce jamais sur des cas
individuels
je connais pas cette personne je sais
qu'elle a commis une maladresse puisque
demandé est ce qu'un plan de suppression
des lits soit appliquée je crois au chu
de nancy en pleine crise simplement ce
que moi je dénonce je pense qu'une des
leçons de cette crise c'est la
bureaucratisation d'état le premier
ministre tout à l'heure d'ailleurs dans
une question il ya un peu répandue
notamment parce que il a indiqué que
vous savez pour l'autorisation donnée
aux laboratoires
l'analyse départementaux il a fallu
bousculer des normes il a dit et que
c'est souvent difficile
donc moi je demande à ce que ce soit en
temps de crise en tout art de guerre
comme a dit présent république le
politique qui gouverne la capacité par
exemple des laboratoires départementaux
des analyses et les 80000 tests
sérologiques par jour c'est considérable
alors pourquoi avoir tant tardé voilà je
pense que encore une fois une des leçons
de la crise c'est que la
bureaucratisation de l'état est un souci
est que en france on a malheureusement
un état qui est à la fois omniprésent
meliet aussi un peu de temps parce qu'il
est omniprésent comme ils présents et
impotent merci beaucoup
revenons retailleau d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
nous allons également avoir bien patrick
kanner le président du groupe socialiste
au sénat avant jean patrick hannais
remercie beaucoup de répondre aux
questions de public sénat après cette
séance de questions de contrôle la
patrie de cannes air pour vous justement
puisque l'on parlait des masques faut-il
rendre les masques qu'ils soient
artisanaux ou pas obligatoire pour
les français quand ils sortent de chez
eux on voit un certain nombre de mères
qui prennent des arrêtés
justement pour les rendre obligatoires
dans leur commune aujourd'hui et les
recommandations également de l'académie
de médecine
je crois que c'est le bon sens et était
le bon sens de le faire le plus vite
possible et donc il y à un mois quand
nous avons eu notre première rencontre
de crise à matignon le 27 février un peu
plus d'un mois maintenant ils auront dû
prendre cette bonne décision même de
manière progressive
je regrette ce changement de pied
manifestement ce changement de tactique
ou de stratégie peu importe du
gouvernement qui en fait est simplement
l'aveu l'aveu que on a sous-estimé les
besoins en masques dans notre pays et
surtout on a pris un peu en otage les
français qui auraient mérité sûrement
une meilleure réponse institutionnelle
vous estimez que la crise a été mal
gérée au moins au début par le
gouvernement et notamment sur cette
question de la gestion des matches je ne
suis pas dans l'esprit polémique
à ce stade nous posons des questions
nous l'avons fait encore tout à l'heure
sur des réquisitions qui ont lieu en
bourgogne franche comté il y à 48 heures
non nous faisons notre travail
le moment venu l'heure du bilan sera
intéressante pour l'ensemble des
français pour éviter que des erreurs
puissent reproduire
manifestement je ne sais pas s'il ya eu
la préparation d'impéritie de la curie
éventuellement ce sont des mots forts je
le reconnais mais il est clair que sur
ce problème par pratique des masques
on a sous-estimé manifestement l'intérêt
pour les français pour nos concitoyens
de les porter au plus vite et tout à
l'heure vous auront posé une question
pour les ehpad notamment pour les
personnes âgées qui meurent
malheureusement silence aujourd'hui dans
ces établissements pour beaucoup d'entre
eux eh bien il s'agissait aussi
d'équipés beaucoup plus vite
les personnels soignants pour éviter que
la maladie ne rentrent dans ces espaces
confinés où malheureusement il ya eu
beaucoup de victimes
justement un certain nombre des masques
commandés par les régions étaient prévus
pour pouvoir équiper les ehpad
qu'avez-vous pensé tout à l'heure de la
réponse du gouvernement sur et bien ces
masques ils disent nous on a priorisé on
a mis là où il était le plus nécessaires
notamment dans le grand est est ce que
pour vous c'est une réponse
satisfaisante le droit de l'acquisition
est prévue par les ordonnances dans le
cadre des habilitations vous avons donné
gouvernement simplement pas comme cela
pas sans consultation des élus pas sans
savoir exactement où ces masques
allaient être livrés le pouvoir d'état
ne peut pas être un pouvoir contre les
locaux nous devons travailler main dans
la main et je ne vous cache pas que la
réponse de monsieur casta l'air était
pour le moins floue au regard de la
précision de la demande de jérôme durain
notre sénateur socialiste sur le sujet
donc je je regrette qu'il n'y a pas plus
de concertation de consultation et
surtout d'efficacité pour cette
distribution des masques dans notre pays
patrick kanner également dans
l'actualité
la question du traçage numérique 1 il ya
eu dans le monde un certain nombre de
précisions qui ont été apportées par
olivier ferrand cédric haut sur ce
projet qui n'est qu'un projet pour
l'instant est ce que vous sur le
principe vous y être favorables et
notamment pour le déconfinement ce
traçage numérique pourrait-il être utile
je suis inquiet ni favorable ni
défavorable je veux savoir comment les
choses vont se passer et j'ai beaucoup
apprécié le rapport de la cnil la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés qui s'est prononcé aujourd'hui
même en disant cela ne pouvait se faire
que sur la base de technique rassurante
par exemple bluetooth pour être précis
sur les smartphones que ça ne pouvait se
faire qu'avec le consentement des
individus est donc une manière
finalement d'encourager le volontariat
sur cette question et puis je n'oublie
pas aussi qu'il y a un quart des
français qui n'ont pas de téléphone
capable d'amener des applications
recteur numérique a trait au tracteur
numérique qui est qui est réel donc
manifestement il faudra une loi et c'est
ça la conclusion de ce propos une loi
qui doit être discuté en toute sérénité
avec le temps nécessaire tant au sénat
qu'à l'assemblée nationale fign
véritable loi une dernière question sur
et bien le tribut qui est payant par un
certain nombre d'élus il ya notamment la
mort du maire de saint-louis dans le
haut rhin qui soulève une vague
d'émotion certains élus remettent en
cause et bien notamment la campagne des
municipales qu'en pensez vous je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec le recul tout le
monde comprend qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
organiser ce premier tour et qu'on
aurait même dû arrêter la campagne
plusieurs jours avant la date fatidique
du 15 mars on a exposé de très nombreux
français
quatre cent cinquante mille français ont
tenu les 69 mille bureaux de vote dans
ce pays et manifestement il y a eu
des infections par ses contacts avec les
votants donc tout ceci montre bien qu'il
ya eu de la préparation et que peut être
au sommet de l'état la bonne décision
n'a pas été prise
quelles que soient les contacts quelles
que soient les éventuelles pressions la
bonne décision pour le pays aurait été
de reporter ces élections est de ne pas
créer une un grand désordre démocratique
qui vient se rajouter à la crise
économique sociale et surtout sanitaires
que nous vivons aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à la question j'ai à présent
accueillir le président de la commission
des lois sénateurs l'est républicain
philippe bas bonjour merci beaucoup de
venir répondre à mes questions tout
d'abord bien effectivement une question
au président de la commission des lois
sur ce que l'on voit se profiler un ce
traçage numériques possibles qui est
évoqué par olivier véran par cédric au
certains craignent que cela pose des
difficultés aussi bien pour les libertés
individuelles faut-il pour autant aller
vers ce traçage numérique face à
l'épidémie
nous ne savons pas encore et le
gouvernement ne le sait pas non plus
simplement on ne peut pas s'interdire à
l'avance d'utiliser un moyen qui le jour
venu et c'est à dire dans un s'est
longtemps hélas nous permettrait de
réussir le déconfinement après avoir
réussi le confinement
il faut bien sûr abordé avec beaucoup de
précaution de circonspection je dirais
et la commission des lois s'est organisé
pour le faire elle a mis en place un
binôme de rapporteur sur la protection
des données privées
elle va auditionner la présidente de la
cnil et je crois que c'est très
important de le faire parce que elle
connaît bien leurs fonctions ces
questions elle décidera aussi des
experts et visionnera le secrétaire
d'état cédric au qui comme vous le
signalez tout à l'heure s'est
publiquement prononcé mais j'ai relevé
qu'il l'avait fait avec une certaine
prudence au fond nous ne devons pas nous
précipiter vers l'utilisation de moyens
dont il n'est pas prouvé qu'ils seront
efficaces s'ils doivent de surcroît
poser des problèmes insurmontables de
liberté individuelle et de protection
des données privées
et ça ne nous interdit pas de regarder
plus en détail cette question parce
qu'on ne peut pas non plus se priver de
la possibilité d'avancer pour que ce
fléau du coffee de 19 soit vaincue vous
avez également posé une question tout à
l'heure en deux parties l'une des
parties est bien porté sur les ehpad où
on en a déploré vous l'avez dit
malheureusement situation mortifère
qu'elle vous pensé de la réponse
d'olivier ferrand qui a bien dit qu'en
droit il y avait la possibilité d'avoir
une personne à côté du mourant pour
l'accompagner dans les derniers instants
si elle a les équipements de protection
mais malheureusement on voit bien que le
problème ce sont ces équipements de
protection
ce sont les masques que non même pas les
personnels encadrant dans certains ehpad
il va de soi que c'est un problème qui
est extrêmement sensible pour tous les
français savoir ce que nos aînés vont
devenir si ils ne sont pas protégés
quand ils sont pris en charge par un
personnel très dévoué mais qui n'a lui
même pas reçu de masques en nombre
suffisant et puis il suffit pas d'en
livrer une fois il faut que tous les
jours on puisse changer ses masques pour
pouvoir être efficace
or le gouvernement avait annoncé que ça
y est ça y était les ehpad allait
fonctionner avec des masques et nous
avons constaté dans nos départements
mais ne constatons aussi par les
auditions que nous faisons la commission
des affaires sociales a reçu ce matin
une personnalité très importante madame
montchamp présidente de la caste
solidarité pour l'autonomie ces lignes
elle s'occupe de tout de tous les
établissements pour personnes âgées et
pour handicapés et est là
ce qui met elle aussi que la situation
n'était pas réglée pour
l'approvisionnement régulier
pas une seule fois mais régulier en
masque de l'ensemble des maisons pour
personnes âgées et pour personnes
handicapées eh bien merci beaucoup
philippe bas d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et nous allons donc conclure
cette série d'interviews avec le
président du groupe
les indépendants claude malhuret tout à
l'heure et bien votre groupe a notamment
posé une question sur un sujet important
aujourd'hui c'est celui de la
souveraineté numérique
y at il beaucoup à craindre pour notre
souveraineté
lorsque l'on voit est bien l'importance
du numérique dans cette crise sanitaire
bonjour je ne sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
à craindre mais il y à pas mal de
remarques à faire en ce moment tout le
monde de travail par visioconférence
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué que ce
soit au niveau même du gouvernement au
niveau des collectivités locales au
niveau des entreprises
tout le monde est grand et par
visioconférence avec des outils qui ne
sont pas des outils français qui ne sont
même pas des outils européens qui sont
des outils la plupart du temps élaboré
par les gars femmes comme on dit on se
posait déjà beaucoup de questions avant
mais aujourd'hui on s'impose encore plus
sur la protection des données est ce que
ces outils respect que le rg c'est à
dire la protection des données qui a été
décidé par l'europe il ya déjà un
certain temps
est ce que ces outils sont des outils
qui permettent la confidentialité est ce
que nos données ne sont pas
immédiatement aspiré vers les pays qui
sont responsables ou celui que tout
c'est toutes ces applications de
visioconférence sondés
développé par des sociétés américaines
qui ont signé le patriot act c'est à
dire qui autorise les gouvernements des
états unis à pouvoir récupérer ces
données le cas échéant par conséquence
ça pose beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes
qui se posaient déjà avant le problème
notamment la souveraineté française et
européenne qui sont soulevées par don
avec cette attestation numérique on voit
aussi un certain nombre d'inquiétudes
qui sont aujourd'hui soulever oui bien
sûr et mai mais dans l'ensemble si vous
voulez la plus grande inquiétude
à terme c'est celle qui existait déjà
avant mais qui se manifeste encore plus
l'europe est en retard sur dans
l'ensemble ce domaine et il est plus que
temps d'essayer de le combler eh bien
merci beaucoup
claude malhuret d'avoir répondu à mes
questions c'est la fin de cette séance
de questions de contrôle au gouvernement
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
toujours pour une série de questions
consacré aux coronavirus ans
[Musique]
e